hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
where we talk about
tech career and life so a really good
friend of mine from college
reached out to me the other day and
asked me mayuko
how do you manage a side hustle
alongside a full-time job he has like a
bunch of great questions relating to
how to manage your time how to balance
these things what to think about when
embarking upon a side hustle
so i wanted to make a video about it
because i thought maybe y'all are like
working and maybe you have a little bit
of time now with the holidays or because
of covid
and so maybe you want to start something
new like a side hustle
by the way i'm going to use the term
side hustle here but like it doesn't
have to be a hustle
i kind of think of it as like whatever
you'd like to do
seriously and spend a lot of time on
outside of kind of your main role
unfortunately it's called a side hustle
because all america can think about is
hustling for money but
you know it's whatever you want it to be
i also think the advice that i'm going
to talk through today
also applies to students who are looking
to work on a side project as well
by the way maybe you're looking to learn
something new as a side gig or
you want to learn something very
specific about the side gig you're
already doing
then i really want to recommend
skillshare who is the sponsor of today's
video as a great place to do that
skillshare is an online learning
community for creatives where millions
come together to take the next step in
their creative journey
they've got courses for everything from
web development to photography
to personal branding to art and
illustration
one really great course to learn more
about how to have
a successful side gig is this one by
andy j
pizza called make creativity your career
six
exercises to create a successful side
project it kind of helps
guide you through all the different
things that you should think about
in creating a side project and it kind
of takes it from the angle of creativity
which i thought was
really cool skillshare is curated
specifically for learning which means
there are no ads and they're always
launching new premium classes
so that you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you
and it's less than ten dollars a month
with an annual subscription
so check out skillshare only the first
1000 people to use the link in my
description box will get a free trial of
the skillshare premium membership
thank you so much to skillshare for
sponsoring and now back to the video
quick background by the way i did this
whole youtube thing as a side gig
for two and a half years alongside my
full-time software engineering role
i would spend anywhere from like one to
20 hours a week working on this thing
and sometimes i would travel for work
but really it was just like
making content for you all really i
tried a lot of different things along
the way and learned a lot on how to work
on a side gig effectively at least
what's worked for me
so i wanted to share this advice with
you today so let's dive in
so i think one of the biggest questions
that most people have when starting a
side hustle
is to figure out how to spend your time
like figuring out how much time should i
dedicate
to x thing and how much time do i
actually have to work on this stuff
and my advice is really just to be
realistic about whatever time
you have because you know what being an
adult
and living life takes a lot of time
because we're
all busy in our own way like maybe have
kids or older folks to take care of
and or your main job is just really
demanding
and as much as we'd like to like stretch
our time and
have more time than we do on this world
we have to be realistic or else i feel
like we're setting ourselves up for
failure
so the thing that i figured out over
time when figuring out how much time
should i spend on something
is to start small so start from like one
to two hours a week on the thing
and then every week just kind of like
grow it or lessen it and kind of see how
that goes
granted every week is probably gonna be
different because we're not machines
and life has ups and downs and waves
that come and go
so it's always gonna change probably
week to week month to month but
just getting a general idea of is it one
hour a week or can
i give 10 hours a week like that's an
important question to ask yourself
the second thing about having a side
hustle is kind of a motivation factor
basically what i think really helps is
to figure out what goals you have
and what you want to achieve with this
thing because if you're doing like a
main
full-time thing or whatever then it can
be really hard
to find the motivation to do a side
thing because
it takes a lot of time and energy to do
the main thing
like there were a lot of times when i
was doing youtube early on that i was
like i don't want to do this
at all because i am so tired and i don't
know
why i even started on this journey to
begin with because i have no energy left
in me but one of the things that really
got me through
was to think about what i want from this
thing to begin with
so i think it's really helpful to
identify this before you start out
and it's also important to re-evaluate
and re-identify as you go along
like are you trying to get joy from
doing your side thing
or maybe it's going to give you a step
up in your work that's your main thing
or maybe it's going to help you achieve
a lifelong goal or is going to give you
something that your main thing does not
give you
already for me doing youtube as a side
thing was a great creative outlet
and was a way to kind of learn skills
that i would never have learned as a
software engineer
not to mention i just like liked youtube
and so it was kind of like
a fun interesting hobby sort of thing
for me too
and so as part of this sometimes it can
be helpful to set kind of a loose
milestone that you're trying to aim for
i say like a loose milestone because
sometimes like setting it in stone can
create a lot of pressure and then just
take away the whole fun of it to begin
with
but just something that you're trying to
reach towards is kind of the vibe that
i'm going for
and so i wouldn't stress yourself out
too much about it because if you're
gonna beat yourself
up for like not reaching it then i feel
like there's no point
but it's always helpful to be working
towards something working towards the
life that you want working towards
finishing something that you've always
wanted to or attaining things
those are really great ways to remind
yourself when the motivation is low
why you're doing this in the first place
so after you've evaluated
realistically how much time you have and
then also identifying like
why are you interested in doing this at
the first place
then it's really just all about
identifying and fine tuning your life
balance
one main point in this that my friend
asked me about is how do you balance
between your main work
and your side work i think the answer is
different for everybody depending on the
nature of your main work but
i was working a 40-hour salary job and
so i set boundaries where i worked
monday through friday
nine to five sometimes more if it was
absolutely needed and it was crunch time
but after five o'clock it was me time
and i always put my full-time role first
because as someone who's pretty
risk-averse
like i didn't want to endanger my
employment
prospects at my full-time role with my
side hustle basically so for me it was
always
full-time real first and then side
hustle second but again you might do
this
very differently for me depending on
what the side hustle is and what the
main hustle is
it's all very subjective but that's just
what worked for me insofar as like time
and energy management goes
i tried a lot of different things to
achieve that balance
and for me there wasn't like this
perfect thing that always worked because
again
life comes in waves things go up and
down life is never
as consistent as you think it would be
but some of the things i tried were
working on my side hustle in the morning
before work
where i have like my bestest freshest
brain
that i could give to the thing that i
was passionate about and then go to work
and then when i'm done with work at five
o'clock i can just potato
and not worry about it anymore there
were other times where monday through
friday i only worked on my main job and
then saturday sunday i worked on my side
hustle
and then there were really just times
where like i did my main job
and then one of the days of the weekend
i slept so much
and then i kind of just like snuck in
time for my side hustle whenever i was
feeling up for it
i think it's actually really important
to develop this skill to understand
what your needs are at the moment
because that's how you're going to avoid
burnout and overwork which can kind of
affect the rest of your life and life is
always going to change too
like maybe you hit a certain age and
you're like you know what
i've got to sleep way more than i have
been in the past because my body needs
that
or you just need like more rest time
more
nothing time and that's okay too so i
told my friend all of these things
be realistic about the time that you
have figure out why you want to do it
and also make sure to
understand your needs and keep a balance
and he said
that all makes sense to me but like how
do i not beat myself up about a lot of
this
and it's really tricky because we're
really critical about ourselves and
sometimes we'll deny
ourselves of our own needs in service of
what we feel like we should be doing
and to that i say i think one of the
most important things about working on a
side
hustle is to take care of yourself this
is where i like really hate the word
hustle because it's
i don't know the word hustle to me means
that like you're compromising your
well-being
to hustle and something else when i
really think you can
achieve a balanced working style to get
what you want out of life basically
sure it might take a little bit more
time but life is all about enjoying the
in-between and the journey along the way
and not about arriving at the
destination so
yeah so taking care of yourself means
making sure
that your needs are met like make sure
to rest make sure to create time to like
do
nothing again we're not machines like i
don't know why people always think that
human beings can be machines
and always output so many things all the
time because
we can't we we're not we're we're not
made that way it is okay to make
compromises
like some weeks you just want to order
takeout because that's all i have time
for or you're willing to compromise your
sleep because you really want to get
this thing done
but i think like just making sure that
when you're looking at the big picture
of everything
your needs are met at some point and
that it's not
a pattern to always be compromising what
your body needs
and i think outside of the physical
things taking care of yourself also
means taking care of yourself
emotionally as well so don't judge
yourself if you feel like you're super
terrible at what you're doing at your
side hustle because
chances are you are new to this thing
and why would you be super perfect at it
at the beginning
everyone starts from somewhere and so
don't judge yourself too hard
don't beat yourself up be kind to
yourself because
you're starting something new and that's
great in and of itself
i mean for like a solid year i was like
oh my gosh i don't know what the heck
i'm doing with youtube i'm
so bad at this and i would compare
myself to
youtubers who had been doing this for
five to ten years who had
perfect videos publishing every week and
of course i wasn't gonna be perfect at
it
but i was trying and after i realized
that i don't have to be perfect at it
i just have to make little things better
here and there
every so often i was eventually gonna
get there you know
and now look at my setup it's so pretty
i'm so proud of this
but this is like two and a half years in
the making of figuring out what works
and what doesn't
so yeah everything is a journey like
starting a side hustle is honestly i
think the hardest thing
keeping up with it is even harder and so
make sure that
you know you're taking care of yourself
in the process so
bonus round my friend also asked me how
did i know
when to take the leap to convert my side
thing into my main thing and honestly i
could make like an entire video of this
but i wanted to just address it
super quickly in like a minute so for me
the way that i knew was number one
financial stability
making sure that my side hustle was
going to afford me the salary that i
needed to live
number two was to give myself a trial
period for this i told myself that i'll
do this for six months and then
reevaluate if it keeps making sense
if it doesn't then i'll go back to a
software engineering job and if it is
making sense then let's just keep going
and re-evaluate every few months
and the third thing was to figure out
whether it was something that i could
actually enjoy
spending 40 hours a week doing by taking
a couple of vacations here and there
and doing like monday through friday
nine to five simulations of this thing
so yeah it's basically just like
collecting and examining past data and
projecting
future data in many different ways
anyway i hope that was helpful
i really enjoyed having youtube as a
side gig but there were times where i
just like didn't post videos for like
two to three months just because i
couldn't
work was too intense or i just really
needed to rest or something and that's
okay that was in the end of the road and
i'm here now
if you have any specific questions about
how to do this side gig thing
then let me know in the comments down
below i will try to get to them to the
best of my ability but realistically i'm
most likely to answer within the first
two days of posting this video if you
like this video then make sure to
subscribe i'm almost at like
400 000 subs which is like absolutely
wild and i would love for you to be one
of them to get me there
anyway i hope you all are doing well
staying cozy and comfy during this
holiday season and i will see you next
time
bye